AND FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY WITH CONTEMPT AND
IMPEACHMENT.
WE HAVE IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS.
IT IS THE MOMENT LIBERALS, THEY
TRUMP-HATING PRESS HAVE BEEN SO
ANXIOUSLY WAITING FOR.
FORMER DISGRACED FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY IS READY TO CASH IN
ON HIS VERY PUBLIC HATRED FOR
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
HIS BOOK TOUR KICKS OFF SUNDAY.
WE COULDN'T HAVE SCRIPTED THIS
ANY BETTER.
HE IS SITTING DOWN FOR HIS FIRST
INTERVIEW WITH CLINTON SYCOPHANT
TURNED ABC SO-CALLED NEWS
JOURNALIST GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS.
WATCH THIS PROMO.
>> HOW STRANGE IS IT FOR YOU TO
SIT HERE AND COMPARE THE
PRESIDENT TO A MOB BOSS?
>> SUNDAY NIGHT ON ABC.
>> ARE THE THINGS YOU KNOW BUT
HAVEN'T SAID THAT COULD DAMAGE
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> TO THOSE WHO SAY YOU SHOULD
HAVE BROUGHT HILLARY CLINTON
BEFORE A GRAND JURY.
>> THE EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW.
>> WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE?
>> STEPHANOPOULOS, COMEY, SUNDAY
NIGHT AT A SPECIAL TIME.
>> Sean: REALLY?
MOB BOSS.
OF ALL THE PEOPLE, THE FORMER
HEAD OF THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION, THE PERSON
RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING DOWN
ACTUAL DEADLY CRIMINAL GANGS,
SHOULDN'T JAMES COMEY KNOW
BETTER THAN TO MAKE AN
OUTRAGEOUS COMPARISON LIKE THAT?
SINCE COMEY CLEARLY DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT, WE ARE
GOING TO REMIND HIM WHAT AN
ACTUAL MOB BOSS LOOKS LIKE.
AL CAPONE.
NOTORIOUS GANGSTER.
ORGANIZED ILLICIT GAMBLING,
PROSTITUTION, TAX EVASION,
RESPONSIBLE FOR AN UNTOLD NUMBER
OF MURDERS INCLUDING SEVEN
PEOPLE IN ONE DAY WHICH IS NOW
FAMOUSLY KNOWN AS THE
ST. VALENTINE'S DAY MASSACRE.
LUCKY LUCIANO, RESPONSIBLE FOR
WIDE SPREAD EXTORTION,
BOOTLEGGING, PROSTITUTION,
MURDER.
AND WE CAN GO ON ALL NIGHT.
JOHN GOTTI, CONVICTED OF 13
MURDERS, ALSO INVOLVED IN
RACKETEERING, TAX EVASION,
ILLICIT GAMBLING AND OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
MR. COMEY, ARE YOU REALLY GOING
TO COMPARE THE SITTING PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES TO A MOB
BOSS YOU CAN MAKE MONEY?
PEOPLE TIED TO MURDER, DRUGS,
MONEY LAUNDERING, EXTORTION,
PROSTITUTION, LOAN-SHARKING AND
ALL SORTS OF OTHER RACKETEERING
CRIMES.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS?
TO MAKE YOURSELF LOOK GOOD?
DO YOU NEED THE EXTRA MONEY?
JUST TO BECOME RICH AND FAMOUS,
MAKE YOUR POINT THEY DON'T LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
IF HE IS GOING TO USE THE
SWEEPING ANALOGY, I HAVE DECIDED
WE ARE GOING TO USE THE COMEY
STANDARD, I CALL IT, AND MAKE
SOME COMPARISONS.
IF COMEY THINKS TRUMP IS A MOB
BOSS, LET'S TALK ABOUT A FAMILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR ACTUAL CRIME.
WE WILL CALL IT THE HEAD OF THE
NOTORIOUS POLITICAL CABAL.
BILL AND HILLARY CLINTON.
THE CLINTON CRIME FAMILY.
BILL CLINTON HAS BEEN ACCUSED OF
SEVERE SEXUAL MISCONDUCT,
HARASSMENT, EVEN RAPE.
WE KNOW HE LIED UNDER OATH.
WE KNOW HE WAS IMPEACHED.
MEANWHILE, HILLARY CLINTON, WE
KNOW SHE COMMITTED CRIMES.
SHE SHOULD'VE BEEN CHARGED.
SHE MISHANDLED NATIONAL SECRETS
ON THAT ILLICIT PRIVATE SERVER,
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE, DESTROYED
EVIDENCE, CLINTON WASN'T ALONE
IN COVERING UP HER MISDEEDS.
CHERYL MILLS.
SHE WAS A WITNESS IN THIS EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
DECLARED ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE IN ORDER TO ABSTAIN
FROM ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
IMAGINE THAT.
LONGTIME CLINTON AIDE HUMA
ABEDIN POSSESSED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON HER PRIVATE
COMPUTER, UNCOVERED IN THE
ANTHONY WEINER INVESTIGATION.
TERRY McAULIFFE.
DONATING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS TO THE STATE SENATE
CAMPAIGN OF JILL McCABE, THE
WIFE OF OH, DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE.
AND OF COURSE HE IS NOW
OBVIOUSLY OUT OF THAT POST.
HE GOT FIRED.
LORETTA LYNCH.
WE WOULD HAVE BELIEVED THE
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL HAD A
SECRET MEETING ON THE AIRPORT
TARMAC WITH BILL CLINTON DAYS
BEFORE COMEY CLEARED CLINTON.
AND WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
CLINTON CRIME FAMILY, WE HAVE
THE DOSSIER.
USED TO GET AND RENEW A FISA
WARRANT AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATES.
THIS WAS AUTHORED BY EX-FOREIGN
SPY, FOREIGN NATIONAL
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, WORKING FOR
FUSION GPS, HIRED BY THE LAW
FORM AT THE REQUEST OF THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, SID
BLUMENTHAL SHOT THE DOSSIER
AROUND THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
TO THE MEDIA.
DEBBIE WASSERMAN SCHULTZ, PART
OF THE SAME FAMILY.
SHE HELPED BRING THE PRIMARY FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
ACCORDING TO DONNA BRAZILE, AND
DONNA HAD SOME QUESTIONS BEFORE
A DEBATE.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST YOU HAVE THE
URANIUM ONE SCANDAL.
SECRETARY OF STATE CLINTON ALONG
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
HOLDER, OTHERS IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, WHY WOULD WE
SIGN OFF ON GIVING AWAY CONTROL
OF 20% OF AMERICA'S URANIUM TO A
HOSTILE ACT LIKE RUSSIA AND A
RUSSIAN STATE OWNED COMPANY
AFTER THE PRESIDENT OF URANIUM
ONE PUMPED THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION WITH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
WE IMPORT 90% OF OUR URANIUM.
THE NEXT, LET'S LOOK AT THE
MUELLER CRIME FAMILY.
OF COURSE WE ARE ON DAY 329 OF
THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT AND THERE
IS STILL ZERO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
IMAGINE THAT.
NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT STORMY
AND KAREN MCDOUGAL AND THE NBC
ACCESS HOLLYWOOD TAPE.
LET'S START WITH MUELLER.
THE WHOLE WITCH HUNT STARTED
WITH MUELLER'S BEST FRIEND JAMES
COMEY LINKED HIS PERSONAL
POTENTIALLY CLASSIFIED NOTES TO
HIS FRIEND WHO WAS A PROFESSOR
AT COLUMBIA WHO LEAKED THOSE
NOTES TO THE PRESS.
ALSO SET FORWARD THE WHEELS IN
MOTION FOR A SPECIAL COUNSEL
WHICH HE GOT.
ROBERT MUELLER, MORE ON THAT IN
A MINUTE.
STAY FOCUSED ON MUELLER.
DURING HIS TIME AS A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR IN BOSTON, FOUR MEN
WRONGFULLY IMPRISONED FOR
DECADES, FRAMED BY AN FBI
INFORMANT AND NOTORIOUS GANGSTER
"WHITEY" BULGER.
ALL WHILE MUELLER'S OFFICE LOOK
THE OTHER WAY.
MUELLER WAS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE PROSECUTION OF THE WRONG
PERSON FOLLOWING THE ANTHRAX
ATTACKS AFTER 9/11.
BY THE WAY, IN THE CASE WITH
"WHITEY" BULGER, $100 MILLION
PAYOUT AND TWO OF THE FOUR
PEOPLE DIED IN JAIL WHO WERE PUT
THERE, AND THEY WERE INNOCENT.
EULER'S MERRY BAND OF DEMOCRATIC
DONORS.
COULDN'T FIND ONE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS TO WORK ON THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL CASE?
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SCREEN.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
DEMOCRATS, HILLARY CLINTON,
BARACK OBAMA.
NOT A PENNY TO DONALD TRUMP.
WHY WOULD ANYBODY TAKE THIS GUY?
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DESCRIBES
HIM AS MUELLER'S PITBULL, ANDREW
WEISSMANN.
HIS AGGRESSIVE PROSECUTION
TACTICS HAVE CAUSED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TO LOSE
THEIR JOBS, THEIR LIVELIHOOD IN
THE CASE AGAINST ANDERSEN
ACCOUNTING.
EVENTUALLY OVERTURNED.
HE'S ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
IMPRISONMENT ARE FOUR MERRILL
LYNCH EXECUTIVES.
THAT WAS OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS, AND HE
HAS BEEN ACCUSED TWICE THAT I
KNOW OF OF WITHHOLDING
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE BY JUDGES
IN CASES.
WEISSMANN WROTE A NOTE TO SALLY
YATES.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTED WEISSMANN ATTENDED
HILLARY CLINTON'S ELECTION NIGHT
PARTY.
DO YOU WANT HIM TO BE THE
PITBULL TO GO AFTER YOU AND THIS
NEVER ENDING, ZERO MANDATE
WITCH HUNT?
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WOULD YOU WANT THAT GUY GOING
AFTER YOU WITH THAT TRACK
RECORD, AND WHY WOULD MUELLER
EVER A POINT THAT MAN?
THEN ON HIS TEAM, JEANNIE REY.
SHE PREVIOUSLY DONE LEGAL WORK
FOR THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
HUGE DEMOCRATIC DONOR.
CAN WE SAY CONFLICT OF INTEREST?
NEXT, WE HAVE THE DISGRACED
LOVEBIRDS PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE.
BASED ON ALL THE TEXT MESSAGES
THAT SO HAVE BEEN EXPOSED, IT'S
APPARENT THEY WERE OUT TO GET
TRUMP FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO TEXTED
ABOUT HAVING THE INSURANCE
POLICY IN CASE DONALD TRUMP
ACTUALLY WON AND CALLED THEM
PRETTY MUCH EVERY NASTY NAME IN
THE BOOK.
THEY GOT REMOVED ONCE THEIR BIAS
WAS EXPOSED.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, WE HAVE ONE
OTHER CRIME FAMILY.
HEART.
WE CALL IT THE SPEECH CRIME
FAMILY.
DURING HIS TENURE AT THE FBI, WE
ALL KNOW ABOUT THE SPECIAL
TREATMENT HILLARY CLINTON